Welcome to the Man of Recaps. You may have noticed
a lot of these new Star Wars series are bringing
into live action characters that were introduced
in the animated Clone Wars or Rebels. If you love
Star Wars, they're both great and you should
watch them. But if you don't have the time,I got you covered.
To start you off with
the super simplified Star Wars timeline,
the Galaxy went Republic,
Empire, Republic, Empire.
The Clone Wars takes place here, in between
Episodes Two and Three. Remember the Galaxy
was in a civil war between the Republic and
the Separatist Alliance. It stars our Jedi main
characters from the prequel movies, Anakin
Skywalker and his master, Obi-Wan Kenobi.
The Jedi are generals in this war, leading the
Republic forces against the separatist Droid army.
And remember, it's called the Clone Wars because
the Republic troops are all clones. But right at
the start we're introduced to a new main character
who wasn't in the movies, the young Jedi Padawan,
Ahsoka Tano, who's been assigned to Anakin as an
apprentice. She's real fun, calls him Sky Guy,
"Oh, don't get snippy with me, Snips!" And
pretty soon these two are best friends.
But Anakin's not the only one who had an
apprentice that wasn't in the movies. The
Separatist leader, Count Dooku, is
training the skinny goth assassin,
Asajj Ventress. She's real cool, fights with
two lightsabers, and eventually Ahsoka does too,
because I mean two sabers are better
than one. So the show features all
the big characters from the prequel
movies: Yoda, Mace Windu, Count Dooku,
General Grievous, but it also sometimes
features some of the background characters.
That's why, if you ask a Star Wars
super-fan who their favorite Jedi is,
they're saying someone you've never heard of,
like Plo Koon. Padme Amidala has a pretty big
role as the senator for Naboo, and remember,
she and Anakin are secretly married. She goes
out on diplomatic missions, but diplomacy
usually fails, and she has to resort to
aggressive diplomacy. And, of course, there's
Chancellor Palpatine, leader of the Republic,
but secretly he's leader of the separatists
too, as his Sith alter ego, Darth Sidious!
A major new character introduced
in the show is the lovable pirate,
Hondo Ohnaka. The Jedi sometimes
work with him on smuggling stuff,
but Hondo is always willing to betray him if he
can make a bigger profit. But the separatists
can't really be trusted to pay him, so most
of the time he's working for the Republic
as a good-ish guy. But on the flipside is bounty
hunter Cad Bane, who has just a really cool hat.
He's a bad dude that's a cold blooded
killer, and he's a great fighter,
he can hang with these Jedi. Speaking of bounty
hunters, there's a young Boba Fett who's formed
his own little bounty hunter crew. He tries
to get revenge on Mace Windu, who remember
killed his father Jango Fett in Attack of the
Clones. On Onderon we meet a young Saw Gerrera,
who would go on to be a somewhat brutal
rebel leader featured in Rogue One.
And of course, some of the main
characters in the Clone Wars are
the Clone Troopers themselves. Yeah,
they may all be genetically identical,
but they all have their own personalities.
The main one we follow is Captain Rex,
who's in charge of Anakin's Division the
501st. They're all born with numbers, but they
get nicknames like "Echo" who repeats things, or
sometimes just "Fives," whose number is all fives.
The main theme of the Clone Wars is that these
troopers aren't expendable machines like droids,
they're real people. This comes to a head when
the 501st is lent out to the Jedi General Krell,
who treats them like they are disposable,
sends them into suicide missions. It's an
intense military dilemma, do you trust your
commanding officer sees the big picture,
or do you have to disobey orders
when they're clearly incompetent?
But in the end, they realize he's used the cover
of darkness to have the clones fight themselves!
Yes he's actively turned to the Dark Side,
betrayed the republic to join the separatists,
so the clones put him down. But the most
important arc begins with Asajj Ventress.
Remember, the Sith have a Rule of
Two: one master, one apprentice.
Because if the apprentice takes an apprentice,
they can team up and overthrow the master. So
Dooku tries to have Ventress killed,
but she escapes and goes back to her
home planet ruled by the Night Mother, a
powerful witch. She helps to get revenge on
Dooku by buffing up one of the males of their
species, this absolute beast, Savage Oppress.
He and Ventress team up to go kill Dooku,
but it doesn't work, Dooku's too strong. So
Ventress goes off to find new meaning in her
life, She briefly joins Boba Fett's group of
bounty hunters. But the Night Mother has a
new plan for revenge with the strongest of
their species, yes, it's Darth Maul! A super
cool villain that was underused in the movies,
because he died at the end of Episode
One when Obi-Wan Kenobi cut him in half.
But turns out he's a hard guy to kill. He
survived with just the top half of his body
grafted onto spider droid legs! The night
Mother hooks him up with a new pair of legs,
and yes it's happening, Darth Maul
is back! His primary goal is revenge
on Obi Wan Kenobi, he and Savage fight
him a bunch, but they can't beat him.
So now let's cut over to the planet of Mandalore.
Yes, the people with the super cool armor that are
an honor-bound warrior culture. But at the moment
Mandalore has become a pacifist planet, their
current ruler, Duchess Satine, is trying to make
them into a more civilized society. But of course,
there are some who prefer the old ways, and the
fringe group Death Watch is trying to take over.
So Death Watch makes an alliance with
Maul, who's a real smart guy actually,
he like organizes a whole coup. But now Maul
challenges their leader to single combat to
be ruler of the planet. And when you're an
honor-bound warrior culture, that's allowed.
Now the Death Watch leader, Pre Vizsla, has a
super cool black saber sword, the Darksaber!
It was made by an ancient Mandalorian who was
also a Jedi, and by tradition whoever holds it
is the rightful ruler of Mandalore. But now
Maul kills this guy and takes the Darksaber
for himself, and most death watch is like
"All right, cool." Now remember, for Jedi,
romance is forbidden, but if Obi-Wan were
going to date anyone, it would be Satine.
So naturally he goes to Mandalore to rescue
her, but it was a trap, and Maul kills her! Oh,
no, we're crying everywhere. Now one of the
Deathwatch leaders was the orange haired Bo-Katan,
who was never down with the whole Maul
thing. And especially not now because
Satine was her sister! So she rescues Obi-Wan
and Bo-Katan goes to fight to liberate Mandalore.
But it's someone unexpected who defeats Darth
Maul, yes, it's Palpatine himself! He can't
have any rivals for Lord of the Sith. And so it's
time for an epic lightsaber battle! Voom, voom,
Palpatine showing that he's a beast.
In the end, he kills Savage Oppress,
but he leaves Maul alive to serve his
own nefarious schemes. Back on Coruscant,
someone has bombed the Jedi Temple,
and Anakin and Asoka are on the case.
Ahsoka is sent to interrogate the suspect,
but she's like "Oh, I've been set up," and
just then someone's killing her remotely with
the force! And unfortunately, Ahsoka was the
only one in the room, and it sure kind of looks
like she's guilty. So Asoka has got to go on the
run to clear her name, and her investigations
lead her to none other than Asajj Ventress.
But Ventress had no part of this, she's
just working as a bounty hunter now,
and she's trying to be less evil these
days, so she helps Ahsoka, a little
bit. But Ahsoka' recaptured before she finds
proof, and it's like "Yo I'm clearly innocent,
please let's do an investigation." But the
war has clouded the Jedi Council's judgment,
and even Yoda makes mistakes sometimes,
so they expel Ahsoka from the Jedi order.
But her master Anakin believe she's innocent,
and pretty soon tracks down the real culprit.
So the Jedi give her a half apology, Yoda's like
"Our bad, that was." But Ahsoka's disillusioned
with the Jedi now, it's like "Honestly, screw
you guys." She and Anakin had such a close
relationship and it's heartbreaking for him to
let her go, but Ahsoka Tano leaves the Jedi order!
In the next major arc a clone malfunctions,
he kills his commanding Jedi, yes he executed
order 66 early. Fives takes point on the
investigation, and discovers all clones
have a chip in their brain. He tries
to uncover this vast conspiracy and is
brought to see the Chancellor himself, but of
course he is the one behind this conspiracy!
So Fives tries to kill him, but now he
looks guilty, and they put him down! No,
Fives was the loyalest trooper of them all, and
now the truth dies with him. Now let's meet an
elite clone squad, The Bad Batch, because they
all have mutations that make them pretty strong.
They rescue a trooper who was captured by
Separatists, and turns out it is our old friend
Echo, who we thought was dead when he sacrificed
himself a long time ago. But they experimented on
him, he's half cyborg now, and so he figures he'll
join the Bad Batch. Finally, we catch up with
Ahsoka Tano, who long story short befriended
some good smugglers, the Martez sisters.
But she learns that Maul is leading a crime
syndicate, and she gets a visit from Bo-Katan,
who's like "He also took over Mandalore again."
Now unfortunately the Republic can't really help
out, but Anakin Skywalker's like "Yo, girl,
I got you." He lends her Rex and the 501st,
who have painted their helmets orange in
Ahsoka's honor. So Ahsoka leads the siege
of Mandalore, which ends with an epic
lightsaber duel between her and Maul!
In the end the good guys win, and Bo-Katan
has liberated Mandalore... again. But as
we'll find out in Rebels, it doesn't last.
So as Ahsoka and Rex have a touching moment
of friendship after having fought in
battles together all across the galaxy,
the timeline's caught up to Revenge of the Sith,
and oh, it's happening! "Execute Order 66."
Yes all across the galaxy the clone troopers are
mind-controlled into betraying and killing their
Jedi friends! Ahsoka barely manages to escape, in
fact she frees Darth Maul to cause a distraction,
so he goes off to continue... shenanigans.
Luckily Asoka subdues Rex and gets that
chip out of his brain. But all the
other clones cannot be reasoned with,
and it's tragic as Ahsoka
and Rex have to fight them.
They managed to escape as the cruiser crashes,
and it's a heart wrenching visual as Ahsoka
gave them all a proper burial. And so, Ahsoka
Tano is one of the few surviving Jedi, who,
like the others across the galaxy, leaves
her lightsabers behind to go into hiding.
The Republic has fallen, The Empire has
risen! The Clone Wars animated series
comes to an end the only way it ever could: in
tragedy. Now it's time for Star Wars Rebels,
which takes place here during the height
of the Empire, getting close to the events
of the Original Trilogy. On the Planet of
Lothal, we meet young orphan, Ezra Bridger.
He's a small time thief who survives by stealing
from the Empire, he's basically Aladdin. But
today there's another group stealing from
the Empire, and they're not just thieves,
they're rebels! Long story short, Ezra joins their
crew. Their leader is Kanan Jarrus, who's rocking
the ponytail goatee. And he's got a secret, he
is a Jedi! One of the last survivors of Order 66.
But the group's real leader is Captain Hara
Syndulla, an ace pilot and Team Mom. There's
a young Mandalorian, Sabine Wren, who is an
artist and explosives expert. Then there's Zeb,
who is your classic big grumpy
alien guy. And last but not least,
is the team's Droid, Chopper, who is a
crazy chaotic mayhem machine! He's the
real MVP of this team because, with
a paint job, the Empire ignores him.
And because he makes a habit of blowing
up entire Star Destroyers, he's maybe got
the highest kill count in all of Star Wars.
So the crew flies around on their ship The
Ghost, doing rebel missions mostly
here on Lothal. Now at first Ezra's
main contribution to the crew
is being small enough to crawl
through air ducts. But pretty soon he
discovers - woah! He can use the force!
So Kanan takes him on as a Jedi apprentice, and
in general becomes a great father figure mentor
to him. Pretty soon they visit the Jedi Temple
here on Lothal, where Ezra has a vision quest,
gets his kyber crystal, and builds
his own lightsaber! And it's a real
unique lightsaber because the hilt is a blaster,
which is a nice upgrade from his former slingshot.
Hunting them down for the Imperial
Security Bureau is Agent Kallus,
a man with truly epic sideburns. But now that
they're Jedi, the Empire brings out the big guns
and sends an Inquisitor. Yeah they're a group
of Dark Side Force users who have been trained
to hunt down Jedi. And their signature weapon
are these unique circular spinning lightsabers.
Now Kanan Jarrus is pretty outmatched, he was
only a Padawan during Order 66. But when he
thinks Ezra's killed he goes into beast mode, and
exploits this guy's obvious weakness. And so in
the season one finale, the Grand Inquisitor dies.
But this really catches the Empire's attention,
and now they bust out the bigger
guns. Oh, snap! It's Darth Vader.
Kanan and Ezra are way outmatched, through
sheer luck they managed to escape. So now
Lothal is too hot for them, they got to lay low.
They meet up with Hera's rebel contact Fulcrum,
who turns out is Ahsoka Tano! Yeah she's back
and fighting for the rebellion! And somewhere
along the line, she built herself
new white lightsabers, all right,
super cool. Her rebel cell Phoenix Squadron
is still real small, but it's trying to grow.
She sends Ghost Crew to recruit an
old friend, yes a surviving clone,
old bearded Captain Rex! We get one-off cameos
with some future rebel leaders like Princess
Leia and Lando Calrissian. And there's a ton of
episodes with Hondo Onaka, lovable pirate from
the Clone Wars. Because Ezra is a bit of a thief
himself, these two actually become good friends.
Eventually Ahsoka takes Ezra and Kanan
on a secret Jedi mission to an ancient
Sith temple. And here Ezra finds a mysterious
old hermit, yes it is Darth Maul! He doesn't
want to fight because the Emperor is his
enemy too, and he's a pretty cool guy,
Ezra kind of like him. But soon he betrays
them and oh! Hit's Kanan in the eyes!
He manipulates Ezra to use the Sith
Holicron to activate the temple,
which is a big weapon. Then Maul will
make Ezra his new Dark Side apprentice,
and together they'll overthrow the Emperor
and rule the galaxy. But Kanan Jarrus isn't
going to let that happen. Yes he's been blinded,
but he gets lucky and throws Darth Maul off the
cliff. But someone noticed when they activated
the temple - oh, snap! It's Darth Vader.
And this became an iconic Vader line:
"I'm not afraid of you!" "Then you will die
braver than most." But now Ahsoka Tano arrives,
and it's time for the epic master apprentice
lightsaber duel! But when she cuts open his
mask she gets to see it really is her
old friend and mentor Anakin in there.
But at this point Darth Vader has fully
disassociated, "I killed Anakin Skywalker."
So as Ezra and Kanan deactivate the temple,
Ahsoka stays behind to finish off Vader.
But when we see Vader walking away, Ahsoka
Tano is presumed dead. So the rebels have
been searching for a new home base, and of
course it's Chopper who finds one for them.
He befriends an Imperial Droid, AP-5, who
becomes his sassy C-3PO to Chopper's R2-D2.
He helps them find the planet Atollon, not
on imperial charts. And it's a pretty great
base except for the giant spider monsters. Now
Kanan Jarrus is permanently blind, but he finds
a mystic creature Bendu who teaches them how
to see through the Force. Now Ezra Bridger has
buzzed his hair and built himself a new green
light saber, he's becoming a real strong Jedi.
But he started playing with the Sith Holocron,
and flirting with the Dark Side! But pretty soon
Kanan helps him realize the Dark Side is bad.
But now Maul comes back to get that Holocron,
and he makes Ezra open up a Jedi one with it,
which combined will answer any question you want.
And the question Maul most wanted answered is
the location of his old rival, Obi-Wan Kenobi.
And so it's time for the final old man Obi-Wan
Darth Maul duel! But as soon as it starts,
it's already over. Yes, Obi-Wan's been ready for
this, takes him out in one blow, samurai style.
And it is kind of a sad moment as Obi-Wan
just pities Maul, he never had a chance,
was brought to the dark side at a young age,
and lived a life of pain and anger. So now
we know how Maul's story ends, but this
probably isn't the last we'll see of him,
because he was still alive during
this whole chunk. And turns out
Maul still had the Darksaber, so now
our Mandalorian Sabine Wren claims it.
Remember Mandalore was liberated by the
Republic at the end of the Clone Wars,
but immediately the Republic became the Empire,
so Mandalore has been under imperial rule. So
Sabine goes home like "Yo Mom, it's time
to liberate Mandalore!" "Did someone say
'Liberate Mandalore?'" Yeah Bo-Katan
is obviously in. So young Sabine Wren,
with the Darksaber, leads her
people to kick out the Empire!
But Sabine doesn't want to stay here and
rule Mandalore, she's got to go back off
with the rebel friends the Ghost Crew.
So she passes the Darksaber to Bo-Katan,
who has successfully liberated Mandalore...
again. But as we'll find out in The Mandalorian,
it doesn't last. Now our rebels, Phoenix Squadron,
has been outsmarting the Empire across the galaxy.
So now the Empire brings out the big guns, Grand
Admiral Thrawn! Yes the main villain from the old
Star Wars novels, before there were any prequels
or sequels. The story is just part of "Legends"
now, but Thrawn himself is officially canon!
And Thrawn is a real interesting character,
very soft spoken, always calm
and collected. Most importantly,
he is a genius tactician who instantly sees
through all our rebels' tricks. Every time
they escape this season is because he lets them,
he's trying to figure out where the rebel base is.
But the rebels have an advantage, a spy
on the inside, and pretty soon Ghost Crew
discovers it's their old enemy, Agent Kallus!
Yeah there was an episode where Kallus and
Zeb crash landed on a planet, had to
work together to survive. And Kallus,
turns out, is an honorable dude,
who now realizes the Empire is bad.
But unfortunately Thrawn found out he's the
spy, and used his broadcasts to pinpoint the
rebel base! So Thrawn rolls up in force,
ready to crush the rebellion completely.
"I am not accepting surrenders at this time." But
there's one thing Thrawn couldn't have predicted,
the old creature Bendu, who doesn't
appreciate all this fighting on his planet.
So Phoenix Squadron joins the rest of the
rebellion, which has set up shop on Yavin 4,
yeah the planet from A New Hope! They're hanging
out with rebel leader Mon Mothma, the rebellion
has reached its final form. But our Ghost Crew
of course was not in A New Hope. They go back to
their old stomping grounds Lothal, to stop Thrawn
from building his new improved Tie Defenders.
Now Kanan Jarrus makes a big life decision,
it's time to lose the ponytail! Although,
not sure if they should let the blind
guy cut his own hair. Now all series
long it's been kind of assumed that Kanan
and Hera are in a romantic relationship,
but it's never been mentioned or really shown.
But finally it's confirmed, there was never any
doubt, and the understated-ness of their
relationship makes it kind of beautiful.
But tragically just then the mission goes bad, and
Kanan got to use the Force to stop the explosion.
And this is it, there's no other way, Kanan Jarrus
sacrifices himself to save his family! Oh so sad,
for what is mostly a kid's show. Now Ezra Bridger
has always had a strong connection to animals,
specifically the wildlife of Lothal
like the super cute loth cats.
But now the mysterious loth wolves show up who
have a mystical connection to the Force. They
show Ezra the secret back door to the Jedi
Temple, which is a trippy weird space with
doorways to different points in space and time!
Ezra finds one that leads to the Asoka Vader duel,
and just as Vader is about to win,
woah! He yoinks her out of there.
She's like "Wow man, thanks, I
didn't know the Force could time
travel." And she helps him understand
that he can't save Kanan the same way,
because it would create a time paradox. In
fact she goes back to the time she came from,
to I guess lay low for a few
years to not upset the timeline.
So now it's time to liberate Lothal! Our
rebels are vastly outnumbered, but Ezra
gets reinforcements from the loth wolves! Oh yeah!
These things are beasts. Unfortunately just then,
Thrawn comes back, and he is accepting surrenders
this time. And Ezra's brought in for a Skype call
with... Emperor Palpatine himself! He really wants
that Jedi temple time travel, so he's brought
a piece of it here and tries to tempt Ezra into
opening it by showing him visions of his parents.
But Ezra's come to terms with their loss,
and so he destroys the temple so Palpatine
can't get it. Of course there's still Thrawn to
deal with, but Ezra had a secret plan that even
Thrawn couldn't have predicted. In a pretty early
episode we met a real crazy animal, the Purrgil,
that are these whale squid things that live
in space and can travel through lightspeed.
Ezra, naturally, formed a bond with them, and now
he's summoned them here! Oh! An army of Purrgil
taking out all the imperial ships! Not sure if
these things are cute, or eldritch horrors. They
hold Thrawn here as they grab the whole ship,
Ezra's like "Yo guys, sorry, this was the only
way." Because Ezra is taking Thrawn off the board,
by warping them out of here, to who knows where.
No one's quite sure what to do with this
development, except of course Chopper,
who takes the opportunity to blow up
the entire imperial base. And so our
rebels have saved Lothal! And a short
time later, Luke Skywalker blows up two
Death Stars and defeats the Emperor, so all
around the galaxy that day is saved. In the
epilogue we learn that Hera was pregnant!
Yes her and Kanan's son, Jacen Syndulla.
But as for Ezra, he left them a message that
he wasn't gone for good, they just need to
find him. So Sabine Wren is going to take point
on finding him, and she gets help from Ahsoka
Tano! Who's now come back as Ahsoka the White. And
that's where Star Wars Rebels comes to an end.
If you like this recap, hit that subscribe button
for more of the best recaps of TV and movies.